you know you have this dream and
sometimes you need to let loose of that
dream because it's not gonna work out
but I always give the advice that you
know you should really try to stick it
out as long as possible because some
things or good things tend to take a
long time my name is Philip man I'm one
of the founders of chronics the
full-service platform for luxury watches
chronics is a online marketplace for
luxury watches so we have over 600
retailers worldwide who by selling
service their watches for us and we take
care of the shipment the logistics
authentication payment the whole
procedure in the after sales service so
when you buy from us feels like buying a
boutique offline where you have all the
benefits of an online marketplace my
co-founder and I we both started the
business in our kitchen and London made
a veil and we were both watch geeks
essentially and we understood that
there's actually there's no platform for
buying luxury watches online or selling
them in a safe way we thought okay
luxury watch this it's a it's a passion
product it's not a big market but we
realized actually you know it's a 90
billion and your industry and there's no
one doing it so let's just try it so we
bootstrap the business for one and a
half years and the turning point really
came after we raised our first round of
financing because it allowed us to
invest into really marketing and kind of
the technology behind it to get to know
the customer and give a better
experience to the customer and after
three and a half years now we're
probably one of the largest retailers in
the world for actually watches I think
the motivation for me personally is you
are confronted with issues you have no
idea how to solve them it's a completely
new kind of playing field you've never
done this before and you work at it and
you keep trying and trying and trying
and trying and you still haven't found
the solution and suddenly there's just
the spark and you know it solves a
complex problem for you and the
gratification of being able to solve
something that hundred other people in
the company may not have been doing or
they've been waiting for you to do it is
it's quite big because it shows that you
know when you really dedicate all your
focusing your time to something it can
pay off a lot actually watch this may
seem very trivial but actually it's
something what people say for a long
time to really buy this item it's not
something that you just buy like this
it's you know something to mark an
anniversary to market
success in your life so people really
take a lot of time to think what they're
gonna buy where they're gonna buy it so
every time a customer buys from us is a
success